Taylor Swift is seriously styling in  this flirty yellow skirt and crop top  set every time I get to put on one of  these outfits I'm just like I love her  twenty-six-year-old rocked the leggy  look to dinner in NYC on Wednesday she  was joined by her pal a YouTube star  todrick hall who also looked chic in his  graphic tee and baseball cap that is the  best kind of friendship you can have  Taylor accessorized her summery look  with a pair of casual gray heels and a  hot pink bag and threw a black jacket on  over her I wouldn't want to do this if I  didn't have a hundred percent control  over what I wear meanwhile Taylor's man  da middle stain is still filming the  third Thor installment in Australia here  we are beginning of shooting for full  three at the studios earlier this week  he and co star Chris Hemsworth took time  to visit kids at a Children's Hospital